el precio razonable de los contratos de
futuros es el precio indicado por el
cual un comprador de acciones puede
llegar a ser neutral entre comprar
dichas acciones al precio en el mercado
o bolsa de valores y que concuerde con
el precio a comprarlos en un contrato
futuro o bien por otro lado un vendedor
de acciones sea neutral entre vender las
acciones en este momento en el precio
del mercado contra acordar está en una
posición corta o acordar estar del lado
de la venta para los contratos de
futuros y el valor razonable tiende a
ser citado o tiende a darse para el mes
siguiente o en la siguiente fecha de
expiración del contrato futuro y para
ver cómo trabaja esto como como sería
que alguien podría ser neutral entre
comprar algo ahora por 100 dólares y el
siguiente mes comprarlo a 102 dólares
así que pensando de esta manera si
queremos tener esa acción dentro de un
mes o dos o tres meses ellos podrían ir
y pagar los 100 dólares exactamente hoy
y tomarlos y decidir comprar ahora mismo
o tomar el dinero y tal vez invertirlo
en una cuenta en el mercado y así
y generando intereses por las siguientes
próximas semanas y después entonces sí y
comprar el contrato futuro pues habrían
generado estos dos dólares de intereses
y bien si ahora ellos guardarán esos 100
dólares y vieran el precio en el mercado
para el siguiente antes de la fecha
actual del contrato para estos contratos
futuros ellos estarían siendo neutrales
así que puedo gastar 100 dólares hoy o
puedo ponerlo en una cuenta en el
mercado de dinero y obtener dos dólares
como intereses pero de los intereses
sería lo mismo que estar generando
dividendos ahora mismo con el contrato
pero cuando los dividendos pasen para
abc de querrás pagar menos por esta
acción y si estos fueran sólo 101
dólares y el precio del contrato futuro
fueran 101 dólares y dijeras esperen si
el precio del contrato futuro estuviera
en 101 dólares dijeras yo lo voy a
preferir preferirías poner tu dinero de
una cuenta de mercado obtener dos
dólares de intereses y comprar el
contrato por 101 dólares luego entonces
lo mismo pasa con estos 103 dólares de
aquí
bueno yo si quiero tener las acciones
dentro de uno o dos meses y estará
comprando las ahora mismo pero
pensándolo de la otra forma si los
precios llegan a los 103 dólares y yo
soy el vendedor de las acciones en lugar
de venderlas hoy por 100 dólares es
preferible que los necesitemos en este
momento los 100 dólares e invertirlos
para que éstos nos generen los 2 dólares
de intereses y después poderlos sacar y
venderlos dentro de un mes por 103
dólares así que el precio adecuado es el
precio al cual el comprador y el
vendedor están neutra decente de comprar
y vender las acciones o bien entrando a
un contrato futuro y de esto hablaré un
poco más en los siguientes vídeos porque
los precios de apertura en los mercados
de dinero van cambiando constantemente
dependiendo la demanda que tenga dicha
acción así que como puedes imaginar si
el precio no es razonable y está por
debajo quiere decir que hay demasiada
demanda y esto es común en el mercado de
futuros